[Musique]
envoyer des collégiens réunionnais aux
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques 2024 à
Paris c'est un projet inédit que le
département de La Réunion a voulu
initier sur l'année scolaire
2022-2023 en lien avec ses partenaires
le rectorat l'UNSS et la CASDEN le
principe 24 collèges et donc 24 équipes
s'affrontent tout au long de l'année
lors de différentes épreuves pour à la
fin désigner une seule équipe gagnante
qui remportera son billet pour les JO
2024 département porte toutes ces jeunes
vers l'extérieur l'idée c'est vraiment
de les faire sortir de l'île leur
montrer que le monde est grand et et
cette initiative de les amener jusqu'à
Paris parce que pour les plus chanceux
d'entre eux ça va être un voyage
jusqu'au village des athlètes ces Jeux
Olympiques c'est juste un rêve pour la
plupart d'entre eux je voudrais
féliciter tous les collèges qui ont
répondu favorablement à ce
agréable challenge les filles les
garçons les enfants qui ont une
pathologie
tous ensemble fédérés vraiment autour
d'une équipe qui gagne bravo les classes
de 5e des différents établissements se
sont affrontés lors d'une première
journée d'épreuve sportive ce mercredi 3
mai au complexe de Casabona à
Saint-Pierre alors les épreuves
aujourd'hui sont des épreuves qui sont
adaptées à tous les Marmaï on a des
filles on a des garçons on a des grands
des petits on a des élèves à besoin
particulier et donc nous les accueillons
sur du basket sur du biathlon alors le
biathlon c'est du tir laser et course
nous avons du tennis de table et de la
natation voilà la deuxième journée donc
ce poursuivra à Sainte-Suzanne cette
fois donc le 31 mai prochain on
reprendra les mêmes collèges les mêmes
équipes donc pour l'instant rien n'est
joué puisque les élèves vont devoir
s'affronter sur des épreuves artistiques
des profs d'éloquence également sur un
quiz avec le partenaire la case d'aide
grâce à ce challenge le conseil
départemental de la Réunion labellisé
terre de jeux 2024 espère bien valoriser
la place du sport dans la société
réunionnaise mais aussi faire naître des
vocations parmi nos jeunes
[Musique]